the last Jedi trailer is here and we
have got the best reactions plus Max and
Vanessa put their differences aside on
Dancing with the Stars
everyone there's a lot of awful stuff
happening in Hollywood right now but not
here because we are about to geek out
over the Star Wars trailer it is out and
people are losing their minds over the
last Jedi teaser including Kate Hudson
who was freaking out when she saw it and
thankfully her Marshall co-star Josh GAD
got it on tape now this is all very
exciting it's even got this casual Star
Wars fan hooked but you know who really
can't contain herself
our very own ash crossing can you tell
part nation how are you holding up I was
like that pork in the trailer well let's
talk about this trailer the last Jedi
picks up where the last one left off
with Daisy Ridley's rain meeting up with
Luke Skywalker but the big question
based on the trailer is just really go
to the dark side see this is a big
theory but I think the trailer alludes
to the fact that Luke will refused a
train ride thus sending her to kylo Ren
and to the dark side however the
apparent meeting between them it sounds
like a misdirect I don't even believe
that they're actually in that same scene
together so you're saying we've been
you've been pulled a fast one on suits
we've been duped okay but let's talk
about the real scene stealer in the
trailer is the porn I called this okay
let me just say I tweeted earlier that
day that the trailer was just gonna be a
screaming pork to camera and Disney did
not disappoint it's clear to say it's
safe to say the poor grip session has
officially begun if you can't tell
already so you're a couple of my
favorite tweets based on the trailer uh
how Star Wars the last Jedi
got me yep I see you Jar Jar and one
from none other than Star Trek's William
Shatner who tweeted this I think Star
Wars has officially jumped the shark
wasn't Mark Hamill supposed to be in
this movie well William Shatner has
spoken are you guys there's plenty more
to dissect from all of this so be sure
to catch Ash's full breakdown of the
last Jedi trailer on a new episode of
behind the screens tomorrow thanks
Ashley the porks be with you
are you guys well Star Wars fans were
shook over the last Jedi trailer it was
just as emotional at Dancing with the
Stars last night the stars put it all
out there recalling their most memorable
year which means there was all the tears
but all eyes were on Maksim Chmerkovskiy
and Vanessa Lachey after max skipped out
on the performance last week due to a
personal issue now there have been
rumors of a behind-the-scenes feud which
they seemingly put behind them how do
you get through it I mean there's so
much tits right of the your from your
heart how do you focus on what you got
to do you channel it you know Wow like
he's a great teacher and I listen as the
student because this is not something I
do well I like to see you guys back
together again
everything right here you guys are going
good I'm so excited about next week cuz
it's Disney I don't think I can cry
anymore and I don't think I I think next
week will be a happy
you think I'll cry at Disney bunch of
Disney Princesses that folks is Vanessa
and Max dance it around the question
after rumors of a feud I can't tell
they're just plain to camera or not but
alas meanwhile Vanessa's hubby Nick
who's competing with Max's wife Peeta
found himself in the bottom two once
again while Frankie Muniz showed off his
resilience the actor turned race car
driver opened up about his health
struggles including long term memory
loss
he says he can't even remember malcolm
in the middle' not actually sure how my
memory loss started I have had nine
concussions I've had a fair amount of
mini-strokes are you able to it to like
congratulate yourself a little bit I
know you're a little bit hard on my
tomorrow myself you know I'm happy that
we got through it because based on like
dress rehearsal my ankles were really
weird this week like today I feel like
every day it's like something we're new
and just to make me neurotic so like I'm
hard on myself and like man I could have
done better but I'm happy my ankles
didn't collapse and you know I fall on
the floor so that's always a win I love
you pulled out Bryan Cranston in your
pre-tape package I'm waiting to see him
and I know it was also using London this
life for the next the fact that even you
know
I was so grateful cuz he's such a great
guy and so supportive everything I do so
he's awesome I know you've had a lot of
different partners through the years on
this one stars there's something about
this guy he's just so infectious my
favorites and all my I called this at
the beginning but Frankie Muniz is the
Dark Horse of Dancing with the Stars
this season definitely the one to watch
I'm moving on to some exciting movie
news Sylvester Stallone has been tapped
to direct creep - that's right the rocky
spin-off is getting a sequel this time
with rocky himself behind the camera and
Michael B Jordan back in the ring that
is happening next year but in the
meantime slide reunited with his
on-screen son from Rocky Balboa Milo
Ventimiglia Milo got sly onboard for a
guest spot on this is us tonight and we
have your sneak peek my sister Kate oh
yeah
pleasure pleasure she's happy to meet
you too hi hi Sylvester Stallone flies
the slide good okay sly you know he came
in the makeup trailer and he's talking
he's making jokes being awesome is one
of the one of the best career expense
experiences I've had in the past so to
be able to pick the phone up and call
him and said hey would you like to be a
part of this we'd love to have you and
then for him to respond and be like yeah
I totally want to be there and it was it
was great it was exciting so and he'd
had a blast so you guys can catch fly on
this is us tonight on NBC and then head
over to et online.com for a full recap
of the episode and we'll be back
tomorrow with more of this entertainment
good good just hit subscribe and we'll
see you then bye